instead of like listening that's modern
because femininity is just taking in
what people say okay incredibleness yeah
so you've been sold this idea as
spirituality that that involves or
includes this level of hyper gummy that
allows you to constantly reframe things
in a way that tends to suit the modern
female Narrative of like you know me me
I'm I'm high value I'm worth more you
know that kind of thing because yeah it
just I I did the whole like meditation
you know I was a Buddhist in high school
and a lot of the results you you know
your healing doesn't sound anything like
healing to me people I know who have
actually like worked through things are
extremely calm they're extremely patient
they rarely talk you just feel a loving
Aura if you meditate on the heart chakra
that's a Vibe you know no one who
practices heart meditation comes out and
says yeah I'm the best lover but I love
I love I am love that kind of thing it's
not it the words are meaningless the
words are you trying to apply
conceptuality to something and
conceptuality tends to have ego because
they have a concept there has to be
something to build that concept on right
where that words start to define words I
get what you're saying but you've said
no no but we're having a discussion
right yeah so therefore you said Soul
the idea of spirituality it's really
like
it's such a personal thing for me like
it just made a big impact in my life
when I don't feel like I needed it I was
young I was 17 at the time and it's
something that's carried through and
whatever
but I do feel like
I've even lost my train of thought like
I can't even remember what I was gonna
say but I just remember you saying
spirituality and being sold in and I'm
just like no more butts no more feelings
just be
vulnerability
okay you were talking about that's it
you were talking about like healing and
people just going over like old Cycles
right
what would then be your what would then
be your thought on someone who does
therapy like actually sees a
professional and works through let's say
whatever trauma because not all trauma
is an ex sometimes it can be bereavement
therapy which is what one of my
therapies was for people usually think
therapy and they think oh it's an x no
sometimes it can be loss sometimes it
can be sa sometimes it can be different
things so like
how do you view those women then would
you would you say they're just it's all
ego driven or like depends on how you
process it but modern therapy gets it
gets a bit weird because we live in such
an ideological society that you know
therapists a lot of the time tend to
push their ideology onto the goals and
these these women are normally
vulnerable so they've had a bad act
every girl I know that is going to be a
therapist
they're not yeah there's always The
Crazy Ones yeah I should be you know I
should help other women I think I
definitely like you shouldn't
chill like so you know this idea that
we're pushing therapy I think therapy is
just a reaffirming loop of like
ideological people then targeting weak
people their weakest point and then that
recycles because I don't know anyone who
has therapy that just stops they tend to
have you lifelong subscriptions it's
Financial yeah they make they have the
same problem making money you're paying
these people 50 pounds an hour not if
it's free and not if you want not if you
know that you're done with that you're
getting free therapy yeah yeah you can
get free so you can get through therapy
but yeah I mean yeah
okay so I have I have a theory about
therapy it's like
ah this is controversial I don't know if
I want to see it
a lot of times when you have therapy
therapy friends you can talk to and
actually like you can get a lot of the
things you get out of therapy from
friends if you have ones that can
actually hold you accountable but
sometimes it's better to talk to men
like I think the most accountability
I've been to therapy and the most
accountability I get is actually for my
brothers when they're like shut the [__]
up you know what and we're like a
therapist I I don't know I didn't feel
the same like connect yeah like I'll
give you an example I've been in a bad
relationship before like toxic my dad
like told me he's like do you like
torture what the [__] is wrong with you
and I was like damn damn
and it's like as a therapist gonna do
that no that's why I'm like bring back
bullying
and like honestly I think a lot of times
like the problems we have as modern
women is because we've never been
humbled in our life and I think to God I
have brothers that bullied me I have a
brother that called me ugly half of my
childhood thank God I might think I was
a 10 right now and it's like I genuinely
feel like a lot of times
like the best therapy you can get is
like talking to men about your problems
because they'll actually be real with
you but hey they can't be men that want
to sleep with you that's bad they can't
want to sleep with you but like I don't
know I like so sometimes I think therapy
is like a lack of Father figures in the
home and it's like a replacement or a
strong like masculine man yeah I don't
that this is you know don't don't hate
me with all the all the people I know
that went to therapy actually my dad's
what active figure in my life and he's
still in my life and I live with him and
he was actually the first person to tell
me do you like stray dogs
in terms of men so you know how your dad
was just like do you like torture yeah
it made me stop and I was just like okay
but when it comes to different types of
therapy sometimes a whole family doesn't
know how to deal with loss yeah so then
who do you talk to and that's the reason
why I'm like with certain things and
certain types of therapy I'm for it I
agree I'm not I'm not I'm not against
therapy it's just like
there's a lot of crazies I think one of
these things that I learned um
throughout my time was that if
something's free
you're the product
and so you say either the therapy is
free so what's the gain or where is it
where could be like the game but I
always learn if something's free you're
the product which means
somewhere somehow someone is going to
benefit from you having therapy that you
see it as a positive and then you share
it to your friends who then go okay I
should go through therapy and then go
through it but that's like the NHS
no no we're paying for that yeah
so the therapy is from also the NHS as
well like I said if something's free
you are paying one way
so from what I've understood from this
discussion today
healing is like a cliche now it's okay
okay healing healing go ahead let's
summarize yeah healing is a cliche if
people say that they're on a journey
it's like oh my God red flag I feel like
everyone has had that I've not heard
anyone sit not even sit on the face I've
not heard anyone say okay I hear this
but there are people that I know who
have benefited from therapy or there are
people that I know who have that they're
healing and I've seen a difference in
them or there are women who may be very
like
I don't know like very like opinionated
or alpha or this but they also have the
ability to be feminine I've not really
heard like everyone's been so like this
is their opinion why are you looking for
that though pardon it would be nice to
have like a bit of range in because I
feel like everyone's kind of saying the
same I think almost I think just as a
functioning adult we can ensue that
there are exceptions like just yeah but
if there's no one's saying them then but
no I don't think we have to say there
are exceptions like like I can say you
know men have these masculine traits
women have these feminine traits and I
don't need to say every single time
there's an exception like I think it can
just be inferred
so are you are you when you say like
like why what is what came through my
head was like Twitter like for example
if I'm if a woman's like oh may not I
don't want to use the wrong word may not
whatever drink and sweat okay I'm in the
trash no yeah or something like that
yeah then you get tons of guys who are
like not all men and then the woman will
be like yeah I know not all met do you
know what I mean but we're coming
because that that is ensuing the the
exception is good man that that's that's
why that that statement's just false